The electric car maker Tesla is set to open
its first European factory in the coming weeks.
The company has thrown a party to unveil its
new plant just outside Berlin – but it's
not without controversy.
Environmental concerns mean its construction
has not yet been given final approval – but
that hasn't deterred Tesla founder Elon Musk.
Nobody could accuse Elon Musk of being short
on ambition, or showmanship, for that matter.
And his plans for the new Tesla factory just
outside Berlin are characteristically big.
"We're expecting to have on the order of 12000
jobs, maybe more.
In fact, I'm a little worried we won't be
able to hire enough people.
So really kind of need great talent to come
here from all around Europe."
A fairground atmosphere prevailed in the factory
forecourt, drawing in curious visitors and
Musk fans from Berlin and further afield.
Some had queued since early in the morning,
to get a sneak peek behind the scenes, temperatures
close to freezing couldn’t dampen their
enthusiasm.
Emil and Erno were among the thousands who
made the pilgrimage.
"I'm excited.
Because I'm here for the first time in a couple
of months.
And the last time I was here it was just a
clean field with some trees.
And now the factory is here."
The factory aims to deliver up to half a million
electric cars a year to the European market
- Musk says the first cars should roll off
the assembly line in just six weeks' time.
But for many, Tesla is more than just a car
maker – it is a complete concept for a hi-tech
green future.
"We are part of the Tesla owner Club.
There's a huge following, huge number of these
people that actually bought the cars.
But actually bought into more than the car,
but in the vision of the company itself."
Despite the hype, the project has encountered
stiff opposition.
The plant is nearly finished, but Tesla was
never officially granted a construction permit.
Some are angry that the factory lies in a
protected water catchment.
German authorities are still examining objections.
"Our demand that the factory be dismantled
has not changed.
It sits in the middle of a water-protection
area – a huge breach of law and a danger
to the main water source for 70,000 people."
Elon Musk is not concerned about the criticism.
In halting German he thanked his adoring fans,
and urged them to join the party.
"Diese Party ist für euch"
Visionary pioneer?
Savvy businessman?
Or just another eccentric billionaire?
Elon Musk has polarized the world with his
unorthodox style and ambitious ventures.
The new Tesla factory outside Berlin is no
exception.